was on a walk with Calvin
and this like beautiful tall
dark
woman walked by I don't know what she
was really not
African-American if you can't even say
that nowadays and she walked by and
Calvin said let me let me get this quote
right she's brown like sheriff toadster
and has boobs like Mommy
Google sheriff toadster sheriff
toadsters Brown he's from the
video game that he plays
and that woman was Brown
and she had boobies like Mommy sorry man
but I don't I wouldn't have said it but
he actually does you are brown like
Sheriff toaster
and you know my wife has boobies uh so
anyway it was nice to meet you uh come
on Calvin let's go Sheriff toadster you
know